BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
We missed you!
Today is our 150th episode!
BAU BAU!
Bobo!
We did it!
Yeah!
Big 150!
Thank you!
Confetti again!
Confetti!
Confetti, please!
We did it
You made it!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
I can't believe, you know, it's been 150 mornings together with you, but they've all been different.
Oh, that's super silly!
It's not a good thing!
It's a good thing, right, Ruffians?
They've all been different.
Thank you FUWAMOCO!
Bye bye!
You missed us!
We missed you FUWAMOCO!
Wait, I have a question.
A question?
Why are you always in front of me?
What kind of bottle is shoulders now?
I think this is a nose.
Well, I'll just let you two go again.
Ruffians!
Which one was it?
Huh?
I don't remember.
Yes.
I don't know.
Uh-oh.
Maybe it's this way.
BAU BAU!
I can't remember, it's only been 150 episodes.
FUWAMOCO is joining us for the very first time today for a very special 150th episode.
To explain a little bit about what FUWAMOCO Morning is, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show.
Help every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING!
Let's go BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
150 times!
One hundred and fifty!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I have too many more to choose!
BAU BAU!
Well, it's a new week.
It's episode 150.
I'm going to try to make it snappy.
Snappy?
What?
Because FUWAMOCO Morning is supposed to be a short format morning show, right?
That means 150 minutes there, right Moco-chan?
That's what it means, right Ruffians?
Short.
Wow, Moco-chan, you know Mondays are a little rough sometimes.
They're a little bit nasty, right?
Are you feeling Monday blues?
Yeah.
You know, usually in the very beginning something nasty happens.
There's a Pero sliding.
Maybe there's some Ruffians that are feeling a little bit sensitive towards things that are nasty like Pero today.
A bit sad.
Yeah.
That's okay, so you can just, you know, maybe make things quiet for the first five minutes.
Okay.
It's okay, today's a special day.
I'm ready for the Pero Sighting.
There has been a Pero Sighting.
I didn't mean to say it, Moco-chan.
Okay.
Pero is not nasty!
Well, wait until you see the Pero Sighting.
Let's take a look, Moco-chan.
Okay.
De-den!
Who's knocking on Monday's door, huh?
Pero.
But Ruffians, even if Pero's nasty, we don't go back to bed.
No.
Yeah, we have to face the nasty things head on sometimes, right?
Let him in?
Huh?
Do you see how he's a brave?
He seems super trustworthy.
I don't know either.
Nice gift.
I think if we open the door, we need to make sure we're ready.
Right.
Preparation.
Yeah.
Safety.
Maybe something like pudding.
Preparation.
Cat.
Or maybe... Scissors?
Scissors?
A rock.
A rock would be good.
She doesn't have paper.
She has a knife.
Rock beats knife.
Yes.
What?
Yo!
Is this trying to cut a cake?
Is it your birthday, Ruffians?
Maybe it's your brain cake.
Ha!
Well, uh...
If you don't have anything like a rock or anything, um, at least, you know, uh, when there's something nasty, I feel like a warm drink, like some tea, like a nice cup of tea might be helpful.
So, maybe.
That's my recommendation.
A cup of tea.
Make everything nasty a little bit better.
Moco-chan, forget about this.
Throw the tea on him, okay?
There was some news recently, Ruffians.
It's been a little bit rougher news.
But the other day, our very beloved Shio-senpai of hololive's second gen, beloved Kusogaki Witch, she graduated.
And of course you know she had a beautiful 3D graduation live.
And it was joined by many friends for some final performances as well.
Also, Chloe-senpai graduated!
In case you didn't know, Chloe-senpai ended her streaming activities earlier this year.
It was a surprise sequel there, but also you know, nice to be able to see Shion-senpai and Chloe-senpai together again.
But it ended very beautifully with some emotional performances!
You know, our favorite major bias, Shion-senpai's original song.
And then lastly, her final original song that she just released, Shion.
That was really touching.
And you know, it's hard to say goodbye.
But we're excited for all the amazing things waiting for him in the future!
You know, FUWAMOCO, we only had a few moments together with Shion-senpai, but they were all really special.
And you know, we are so happy recently because we finally were able to talk a little bit more, you know, during the hanami we did together.
All thanks to Suisei-senpai.
We're happy to end it off like that too.
Thank you so much Shion-senpai for your 7 years!
7 years!
Thank you.
Amazing.
BAU BAU!
It's more rough news but just yesterday we said goodbye to Mumei-senpai hololive English -Promise-.
She also had a very beautiful 3D graduation live.
But that's not it!
You know she left us some very wonderful presents beforehand.
Did you see it?
All the cover songs she released!
She released a cover song of Don't Wanna Hold together with Kronii-senpai on Kronii-senpai's channel!
Have you listened to it?
It was so cool.
Well you have another song to listen to.
And!
Thank you.
She also released a cover of Tottomae together with Korone-senpai and Mumei-senpai!
Yes, I know!
I wanted to try to say Korone-senpai and Korone-senpai at the same time!
Hi!
What does it become?
Korone.
Yes!
And!
Mumei-senpai also released a cover of Best Friend together with Bei-senpai on Bei-senpai's channel.
It's really really good.
Amazing cover.
And then she also released a cover of Gravity on her own channel.
Gravity is a really really special song to us too.
A song that we have listened for a long time.
I saw it meant so much to us and I'm sure Ruffians that there's so much emotion packed in it.
Yeah.
Mumei-senpai left behind a lot of songs, a lot of songs!
What's that for then?
Because there's a thousand!
Another, another comment!
The last song that she left us a very special Tadakoi Hitotsu.
That's also Mumei-senpai's channel.
The last one on her channel.
But apparently, she mentioned that she has more?
Wow, coming out!
I don't know.
I don't know, but you know... That's amazing.
Mumei-senpai left us so many wonderful memories, so many amazing songs and works, so we're really happy to have even more to be able to treasure to you.
And congratulations!
Congratulations!
You know, we all sang together, we were able to sing Mumei-senpai's very special original song,
You know, we feel like maybe we weren't able to, but...
More than anything, we just want to be able to... You know, treasure those good memories that we had.
We didn't want to make them more sad.
You know, the last time we talked together... We didn't get to talk about the things we wanted to talk about!
You know, so...
But I'm sure you know we're not the only ones that feel that way.
That's all.
But more than anything, let's remember the good times!
I know!
All the silly things we did together!
Overwatch!
And you know we're really looking forward to playing more Overwatch together!
FUWAMOCO.
And you know seeing FUWAMOCO play was here in Japan as well.
We had to take her to it once.
She has to learn.
It was a lot of fun.
Thank you FUWAMOCO for everything!
We'll always, always remember everything you've given to us.
Thank you for being a sweet girl.
BAU BAU!
Wow, there's a lot of news, a lot of things going on.
But, there was also another 3D live that happened.
Kiara-senpai, she had a 3D concert, a spring concert.
And FUWAMOCO and a bunch of EF members were all there, just the two of us.
We were there!
We were so happy.
It was a very special idol live.
It was all Hello Project.
Hello Project is an idol agency.
Hello Project songs.
And we got to perform Amanojaku from Smilage.
It's been stuck in my head forever.
Right!
And also Rival, a song by Berryz Kobo.
And it was so much fun.
Especially Rival together with everybody.
But you know, I saw Kiara-senpai.
She was really happy to be able to do all these songs she loves together with everybody!
But us too!
You don't see everybody performing these hello pro songs!
It was really great!
It's a strange feeling, huh?
Hiyara-senpai too!
Right!
Y'all always have fun!
Fun, fun, fun!
But Kiyara-senpai also unveiled a brand new original song!
Perfume!
Look at her here!
So beautiful.
But it's a super stylish and poppy song and it's a definite check out, okay?
Especially the music video here!
Daura-senpai is so pretty but... Daura-senpai?
Daura-senpai!
Daura not-senpai!
Also designed a bathing suit for her!
So please check it out!
That means it's a bathing suit scene.
Not Daura-senpai.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Have a howl of a day!
There's been a lot going on!
Recently in exciting Advent news, well, there's something going on in Shibuya!
BAU BAU!
At Shibuya Tsutaya!
At Shibuya Tsutaya's IP bookstore, together with Design Coco, they started a new brand,
Good!
What?
Just to celebrate, you know, two anniversaries.
Anniversary Shibuya Tsutaya reopening and IP Bookstores reopening.
Oh!
Yeah!
That's why it's special.
Yeah, and Advent, you know, we're there to celebrate!
Yeah!
Look at us here in our Zeo Gravity Battle Suit.
Make a list of it, Advent!
Are you ready?
Yeah!
Oh, BAU BAU!
Mama!
But you know what?
Just us advent pop-up shop with super cool outfits.
And there's a bunch of, you know, different words.
But I... But Moco-chan, what... Huh?
Well... Why is cheese the eye?
FUWAMOCO figures will be on display.
But!
They sorta... Didn't say what size the figures are.
Life size!
If you need it!
Look at the morphins!
What's that?
Oh my gosh!
Can you believe it?
Their life size is one life scale.
Lots and lots and lots of them.
But right now, the most important thing, they are on, not the life size, but they are on priority right now.
Yo, you can take a home!
1-7-Skimmo.
1-1-2-Bad.
But they're on pre-order right now, you can get them.
Also on AmiAmi!
Yes!
I think there was some confusion.
We're gonna talk about it more later because we don't have much time.
But, so, there is a deluxe version.
And it's more individual.
They are set to get set.
So, it may be a bit pricey.
But there is a non-deluxe version!
And it's not a set, so maybe that's a bit easier.
You know FUWAMOCO are kind of a set, right?
Kind of a pair, right?
But sometimes the world doesn't accept pairs too.
It's pre-ordered!
The pre-orders are open!
It's made to order.
It's made to order, you know.
So, Ruffians, sometimes, at FUWAMOCO, sometimes, they're like, oh well, maybe, you know, after it comes up, then I'll get my paws on it.
It's made to order.
You know, the chances that you'll be able to find it, that means that a Ruffian had to be like, I don't really know about this figure anymore, and then decided to say goodbye to it.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's gonna happen that much.
Don't regret things like FUWAMOCO has before, okay?
BAU BAU!
By the way, there is a giveaway!
There's a giveaway, Ruffians!
If you go and retweet it again.
Yes!
But, if you go over to Twitter and you follow and follow the AskRin account, not just FUWAMOCO, although that makes us happy, but follow the AskRin account and repost the retweet.
If you follow and retweet them, then you could be entered to win the video.
Not the one-one scale.
Not the one-one.
This song would be nice.
We'll talk about it way later, okay?
BAU BAU!
We still have a lot to say!
Also, just the other day, we were in Osaka for Japan Expo!
BAU BAU!
We're at the big Osaka Expo that's happening right now in Japan!
Right!
Have you heard of it?
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
And you know, it was our first time performing on an outdoor stage.
It was beautiful.
Everyone lit up the night sky with their palm lights.
The weather was nice too.
We were super touched.
Thank you FUWAMOCO!
But it was really nice to be able to see so many fans hololistic of all ages unite and be able to see and hear the support for everybody together.
FUWAMOFRIENDS we definitely heard your cheers, your BAU BAU's, and the FUWAMOCODES too!
Thank you!
Thank you for letting us be happy!
We'll be happy!
Thank you!
But it was a huge honor for us to perform at such a big event!
Yeah, with so many people that, you know, still aren't familiar with hololive or VTubers!
I know!
Very exciting!
We hope we can perform at more performances like that and reach even more people in the future too!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, it's a big international event.
It really is!
We are so happy!
We weren't happy.
Ruffians.
I know it's been a little while, but... Ruffians, there's been a misunderstanding.
Actually, a lot of misunderstandings.
So, you know, we have to clear them up.
And, you know, so to be able to clear them up, we went the rest of the year and we asked them for their misunderstandings.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
Here we go!
BAU BAU!
Hello.
My name is Shiori Novella, hololive's archiver.
And I would like to clear up a little misunderstanding.
You see, when people look at me they think, oh, she likes blonde anime boys.
But the reality is a lot more complicated than that.
Now if you look at this, I prepared a little simple slideshow.
This is Dimitri's gradient from Fire Emblem Three Houses.
Does it look blonde?
Yeah!
But you know, it's not just because he's blonde that I like him.
It's about the personality.
Because as you can see, if we move on...
Gilbert from Unicorn Overlord?
This pale color here?
Yeah sure, you can classify it as a type of blonde.
But what about this character?
Aramis, or Aramis.
He is also blonde, but you know what?
I didn't like that.
He was okay, sure.
But I didn't think that he was as interesting as Gilbert over here.
Or what about even Dimitri, who has a higher contrast and blondification.
So if you look at these, blonde, but not interesting.
So being blonde isn't everything.
Now what about here, Ryo?
Yeah, sure!
Also looks a little blonde.
Could be even whitish like freaking Kaneki Ken.
But as cute as Ryo is, he's also a little... Well, I think spoilers might be okay.
But I think he's a little bit of a deviant.
A little bit of a devil, so... Blonde, cute, and really attractive and dang!
But not, not good.
Not good for the heart.
Now, if you keep moving on the list, you'll see a lot more variety in the fictional men that I did like.
Well, Mart Lewis from Code Vein.
He's nowhere close to blonde.
Funnily enough, he has the same Japanese voice actor as Dimitri from Fire Emblem.
But you see this?
Not blonde at all.
So, at the end of the day, it is about personality.
As you can see.
Next person.
Stroll.
Looks blonde.
I don't know him though.
The moment I look at him, I don't think like, um, fine, no.
I just think, hmm, not my type.
But the other guys speak too and he's pretty blonde, but I think that is a coincidence.
And the last one, nowhere close to blonde.
Completely blue.
So, and by defense, and to clear the misunderstanding, it's not just about being blonde, it's about what's inside.
BAU BAU!
I didn't think I was going to understand the misunderstanding, but I understand.
There's no misunderstanding.
You get it, Ruffians?
Yeah.
But, uh, I thought, it's not just that they're blonde.
She likes the blonde personality.
What I took away from this is that maybe we're going to have to look for a lot more different genres when we go and look for doujinshi for Shiori.
That's what I thought.
There's more work to be done.
Yeah, it was quite enough explaining exactly what she wanted to the employee when I don't know what it is.
Because the employee, she kept on being like, which game is it?
This game or this game or this game is this character?
And I was like...
I don't know anymore.
We're gonna have to do some studying.
Yeah, we'll have to study.
No misunderstanding.
That's not the point.
Understood now.
I understand.
Yeah.
OPA!
Okay, misunderstanding.
Understood.
Okay, there's more misunderstanding.
Yeah.
Let's go and find some good Ruffians!
OPA!
Hello!
FUWAMOCO!
It's me, Cecilia McGrimm from hololive Yen Justice.
Speaking to win!
Congratulations first of all for 150 episodes of FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's really cool that you reached this gigantic milestone and I hope you always have fun with it and you keep having fun with it.
Today I am here to clear up a misunderstanding actually.
So, my misunderstanding is that some of my audience have misunderstood that they think that I'm evil.
But, I'm not evil.
And you know this, of course.
You know that I'm not evil.
And yeah, sometimes they say stuff like, uh, is it true that shouldn't justice be evil?
Isn't Advent good?
But no.
No, that's completely false.
And yeah, please explain to everyone that it's false.
Tell them that it's false.
Because I'm really good.
And I'm a really good automaton.
And I've never done an evil deed in my life.
And I've never hated anything.
And I've never done a crime.
And I've never committed murder.
Allegedly.
And yeah, so please clear up this misunderstanding for me.
Okay.
Thank you!
Bye bye!
BAU BAU!
Bye!
Congratulations again!
BAU BAU!
She wants us to clear up that she's not evil, but... Huh?
Huh?
This... Is this how misunderstandings work?
We didn't have any evidence.
Huh?
I think... I think if anything... We'll let you know, because I understand this.
Oh, Cecilia's evil!
Fuwawa's evil!
So you understand.
I understand this issue, this misunderstanding.
It's a big misunderstanding!
It is not true!
But Cecilia, I... Ruffians!
Sometimes... You know, we see everything, okay?
Sometimes... Maybe some Ruffians taking a bit far.
I'm not evil!
I'm Fuwawa!
She might be evil.
That's because Fuwawa accidentally crushed my keyboard which was already being broken and didn't care about.
It doesn't make her evil.
That's because she said she wanted to pull out Mumei's feathers.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
It's up to Gigi.
Would you think that Gigi would lie?
I don't think so.
I think she would know the best.
See?
Mococo knows the best!
Fuwawa's not evil.
So then if you ask Gigi, then she has the answer.
Gigi is biased?
No she's not.
She knows the best.
Oh.
See?
You get it?
So, uh, it's misunderstanding.
Understood.
Is it?
Yeah!
Maybe not halfway.
Almost understood.
We need to ask Gigi.
Okay.
Got it.
BAU BAU!
There's still more misunderstandings, Moco-chan.
Oh my god.
Still more misunderstandings!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Congratulations on your 150th episode!
Now, you probably have an idea why I'm here but... I would like to explain something.
A misunderstanding perhaps that has happened recently to me.
In a...
In the previous stream of a game called Rust, there was an event called the Egg Hunt.
And when you get a golden egg, you can open it and receive a gun.
A gun?
I was trying to tell my lovely kouhai, Su-chan and Shiha-chan, about this
Kintamagun instead of Kino-tamagun.
Maybe I have heard Kin-Tama before, but in that moment my mind was blank under the pressure of my kouhai.
Pressure.
The pressure.
And I had just known that Kin meant gold and Tama meant egg or tamago.
So I blurted out
Kintama Gun!
From my... ...soul?
Mouth.
For those of you who don't know, who don't speak Japanese, Kintama is slang for a particular part of a...
Dude.
Huh?
She just... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just said the... She just
Thus, it resulted in a many shenanigans in my body muscle.
I just wanted to clear that up.
That no, I did not think originally balls when I said shintama.
Balls gun!
I did not, but from here on out, if I do say it, it is on purpose.
Thank you for listening to my misunderstanding.
Arigato gozaimasu.
Sumimasen.
Biboo, later.
I don't think it's a misunderstanding!
I don't think this was a misunderstanding!
I don't think she's having fun with this!
I think she's having fun too high!
Is this FUWAMOCO Morning 150 or not?
I think she's having fun.
It's good though, you know, it's good to make mistakes learning a language.
So, you know, it's a positive mistake.
But she's a bit too proud.
She's happy to learn a new language.
She's a bit too proud.
Learning is good.
Yeah.
Hamago.
Have a hamago for breakfast.
I made a mistake when I said Uma instead of Zuma.
Somebody's wife became a horse.
This one is similar.
Sort of.
You know what?
What was it that you said recently that you were a bird?
What was it?
It's that I was kind of, you know, I was tired.
And I was trying to explain the situation that, you know, that our bags are at the hotel.
And, you know, the bags, nimotsu.
And instead, I said that the hotel they had are nimono.
Instead of nimotsu.
And I just kinda just went silent for a good 10 seconds.
Because nimono means like a stewed food.
Yeah, the hotel's taking care of my stewed food right now.
You didn't want to say anything!
I was just standing for 10 seconds on the lift!
BAU BAU!
It happens!
Misunderstood.
That's hotel service!
BAU BAU!
At least Biboo's leading, right?
Yes!
Kawaii kara yurusu!
Yurusanai!
Biboo's misunderstanding!
It's understood that she's having fun.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
There's no more misunderstandings, right Moco-chan?
That's it, right?
Not a real misunderstanding in itself.
Let's see.
Okay.
I had a misunderstanding pretty recently actually, kind of recently.
I was in a different neighborhood and I thought to myself, oh yeah, wait a minute, someone, an old friend, an old friend, in fact a couple of old friends are in this neighborhood and I'd like to meet with them in the short time that I'm here.
And so I got all excited and I contacted those friends and I said, hey, let's let's meet up.
I'm in the neighborhood on this particular date.
Would you like to go to this particular restaurant?
I made the reservation and everything.
I was so excited.
And that that friend and group of friends were like, yeah, let's do it.
We're so excited to see you again, Mori.
It's been forever.
Looking forward to it.
And so I rock up to the restaurant and I'm chilling there and I'm waiting.
And then it's like 10 minutes past.
And I messaged them again like, hey, so let me know when you guys are going to be here because I'm just hanging out, you know, chilling.
And they won't let me sit down until you guys are here.
So I'm just standing here.
So I was standing outside of the restaurant all alone.
And, you know, all these groups of people passing by me noticing as I get sadder and sadder.
And then after like 45 minutes, I'm like, oh, 45.
I guess they're not coming.
I guess they didn't want to hang out after all.
And they didn't message me back at all.
And so I walked all the way back to my hotel really sad and all these thoughts going through my head.
I guess they really don't want to see me anymore.
They hate me.
Then I get a message back being like, oh my god Mori, what?
You went to the restaurant?
But Mori, the message that you sent us says it's next month.
You wanted to meet next month, right?
I scroll up through my messages and lo and behold, Mori did say in the message to friends, you guys want to meet up?
On this date, and it was a month later from the day that I went to the restaurant and made the reservation.
It was a big misunderstanding.
But man, I felt a lot better after we got that cleared up.
And then it turns out that they actually weren't busy that day, so we met up in the evening!
So everything was fine in the end.
This...
This has happened more times than once.
It happened with one of my other friends who writes manga.
She was like, let's meet up on this day.
And I went to a super far away area that we had chosen to meet.
And I was like chilling there waiting like, alright I'm here sensei, what's going on?
And then she messaged me back being like, Mori, next month, right?
At least it's before, not after.
So let's try and make sure this misunderstanding...
Doesn't happen anymore.
That would be nice.
But you guys know me.
I'm a little... You knock knock on my head, you're gonna hear a big hollow sound.
We love the hollow sound!
BAU BAU!
I'm glad though!
I don't wake up that tired.
Actually though, I feel like... We've been on that before.
Why?
I think it's okay to tell you that, but she makes some mistakes sometimes.
As long as it ends up alright.
Is this... Is this a whole man thing?
Oh!
Getting the month wrong.
Getting the month wrong by showing up on the wrong day and misunderstanding the date.
I feel like it's happened to us a lot too!
BAU BAU!
It better be a month early than a month late at the most.
Right?
Exactly!
I think it's okay though.
45 minutes wasted!
But a funny story gained, right?
Eventually, no.
Yeah, you believe how this happened to us a lot though.
I feel like, you know, Cali-senpai!
You know, she makes funny mistakes like that, it's funny.
Because it's just, you know, like, oh, that's kind of... It happens.
It's a gap, you know?
Before it was pretty common.
Now it's just pitiful.
It's not fun anymore, it's just pitiful.
Yeah.
It's enduring!
Right!
For Cali-senpai.
Yeah.
Not for us.
Inconvenient.
Yeah.
This is episode 159!
There's lots of misunderstandings when it's 150 episodes.
This is the last one, okay?
Last one.
Okay, let's get this misunderstanding understood.
Okay!
BAU BAU!
The next one, I... I feel like it's better this way.
Huh?
This is a message from Gigi!
Okay, I hope it works.
Let us know if it doesn't work, okay?
Good morning.
Hello, FUWAMOCO Morning.
Thank you to Fuwawa and Mococo for giving me the space to clear up some misunderstandings that have occurred on my channel.
My channel is Gigi Moony.
hololive English -Justice-.
Sorry, I should have introduced myself.
I'm Gigi Mooney of hololive English -Justice-, and I have some misunderstandings I would like to clear up on FUWAMOCO Morning.
Sometimes on my channel, Gigi Mooney Channel, you might hear something that sounds suspiciously like barking in the background.
Dog barking perhaps, but it is not.
I would like everyone to know, formally and officially, that it is not a dog barking.
There are no dogs barking in the background.
I want everyone to stop saying it's a dog in the background.
It is a bird.
A bird!
Thank you.
Birds do that.
Birds do that, Moco-chan!
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
I feel scared now, Ruffians.
Do you feel scared?
Have we seen a bird before?
I haven't, no.
Birds do that, I saw it on YouTube.
I also saw a cat make a pizza on YouTube.
What do we believe?
What do we not believe?
Do I not see it with our own eyes, huh?
Maybe that was Nerissa!
A lot of funny things are happening, huh?
A lot of funny stuff, huh?
That was GGOK!
I'm not sure if I actually...
It's all a misunderstanding!
BAU BAU!
I don't know, I don't... I feel... By the way, no misunderstanding understood.
It's more like misunderstanding unsettled.
FUWAMOCO Morning means to you!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
You answered us a bunch of times with, you know, very very special messages, heartfelt feelings over on Twitter.
Thank you for using your hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING150!
BAU BAU!
It made us really emotional, but it means a lot to us to know, you know, just what FUWAMOCO Morning means to you, how it impacts your day.
Let's take a look at some of them!
I see.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning a place to get even more smiles!
There was a time when I found it got increasingly hard to smile.
But after finding you two, I can't believe it myself that I've been smiling and laughing more than years before!
FUWAMOCO Morning definitely does that for me!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
I'm glad that maybe I can help start the day off on the right paw.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a late afternoon for me.
So rather than starting my day with it, it's a nice way to wind down and have fun with a bite-sized dream after a busy day.
I guess it can be a donut then.
I always enjoy the hololive related news and Ruffian submissions!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
FUWAMOCO Morning 150 is usually at the end of a great day for me.
I'm usually pretty tired and would like to go home.
That makes sense.
But seeing FUWAMOCO so diligent with this series gives me great motivation to go to the gym for my workout and listen to them.
I am glad I will probably use gym workout then!
Maybe you're at the gym right now?
Squat harder!
Harder!
Lower down!
You have to go lower down!
Like you're sitting in the chair!
Yes!
Let's do it!
Knees!
Yes!
It's the perfect way to end the day.
BAU BAU!
The FUWAMOCO Morning brings the morning dose of sweetness needed to get through the day when life's rough.
Hearing both girls give such warmth each FUWAMOCO Morning proves that you can always find the bright spot.
Thank you Fuwa-chan and Moco-chan for bringing our days.
I'm crying, you know?
Hopefully, especially, you know, during a bit
BAU BAU
Darker deshita.
One more time.
I can be there for you.
BAU BAU!
Oh, I'm a college student right now, so whenever I get up early, it's easy to do schoolwork.
But getting up on Mondays, Wednesdays, or Fridays is never hard because FUWAMOCO are always there to cheer me on.
BAU BAU!
Even when I'm quiet, I'm always ready to BAU BAU to a new day!
It's time to wake up again!
Classes might be soon.
Hopefully not too soon.
FUWAMOCO Morning is not long today, no?
BAU BAU!
And I'm awake when this stream is live.
I'm unable to watch it, so I can only listen to it.
But sometimes I peek at the stream.
It's relaxing listening to YouTube while I wake up.
Sneaky.
Sometimes FUWAMOCO ask me why I'm smiling, and I think to myself, it's thanks to FUWAMOCO.
For me, it's Japan time, so it's a bit different than most Ruffians.
But for me, FUWAMOCO Morning is a way to end off
That is the stream I end off my day with.
Genki ippai na FUWAMOCO wo mite kara neru.
I watch FUWAMOCO be all energetic and then sleep.
Sono seikatsu ga watashi no taisetsu na jikan desu.
That lifestyle is my precious time!
Itsumo tanoshii jikan wo arigatou!
Thank you for all the fun time!
BAU BAU!
A nightcap!
I'm happy to be a nightcap.
Maybe a little cup of
Hot water before bed.
BAU BAU!
Don't forget to brush your teeth again!
At the start of this year, I broke my leg and couldn't go back to the city where I was studying.
That means no work or study until my leg is fully healed.
Thanks to FUWAMOCO Morning, I have motivation to wake up early and start studying again on my own.
BAU BAU!
I'm glad you know that we can protect your smile when things are really, really rough.
When you get injured, it's such a blow, not only just physically, but mentally, emotionally.
Just take it easy, okay?
Stay strong!
One step at a time, okay?
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita to afternoon on my timezone.
Just in time for work's break, so it always gives me a huge boost to keep the day going, especially on raw four days.
It's a very comfy and relaxing show that never fails to make me smile.
Thank you, FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you so much for all your special feelings sharing with us what FUWAMOCO Morning means to you.
Thank you.
And you know, we thought that we share with you what FUWAMOCO Morning means to us.
I know.
For us, FUWAMOCO Morning is an important time we spend together.
You know, three times a week.
You know, all the time.
And it may not be anything super fancy or deluxe everyday, but you know, it's the everyday time.
Just these sort of silly little moments that we get to spend together that makes it truly special to us, you know.
And, uh, Ruffians!
That you wake up early maybe, or find time in the middle of your day, or right after a busy day, that you find that moment to be able to spend together with us.
It is the life!
It makes it really special to us, and we feel so lucky to have that time with you.
So thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Thank you, FUWAMOCO, for being a part of your life.
It means a lot to us.
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
Hi!
We made it!
Doggie of the Day!
Who's the Doggie of the Day today?
We have De-den!
Today's Doggie of the Day is Gus!
Gus!
Welcome!
Look at Gus!
Gus, what are you doing on the floor there?
Gus is really soft, but I... Why?
I want to pet Gus backwards.
He's so silly!
Wait, does he look a bit... Healthy?
Maybe he just needs headpats!
Maybe!
Gus has been a part of this Ruffian's lovely family for over a decade!
So long!
It's been, it's kinda hard to remember.
Is that the best though?
That means you just had so much good times together!
It's so much fun that you kind of forgot the years, right?
But he's extra silly and I can definitely kind of see if you remove the text there, you can see a traffic cone.
That's so cute!
I love it!
And he's meaty too!
Gosh.
Moco-chan, how does gosh bow bow?
Bow wow.
That's a good tropical one.
I try it.
Bow wow.
Does that sound like Traffic Code C?
I think that sounds just like us.
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Akko's just such a beautiful boy with a lovely neck and underbite too!
Very cute!
Definitely not guilty.
And look at those fluffy ears too!
Right!
So cute!
Even if he's a needy boy, that's okay!
There's nothing wrong with that!
Right!
You have lots and lots of love and cuddles to give him, right?
Lots of high fives and neck ruffles, right?
Okay!
BAU BAU!
If you want to pet the ears, you can pet Gus' ears.
Gus is happy to take the ear pats.
FUWAMOCO no.
BAU BAU!
And next we have... Today I went on a walk with Ruffians!
I've been able to go on a walk with such nice Ruffians!
Let's take a look!
We have... De-den!
What?
A what?
A cafe!
Huh?
Cafe bar!
Oh, a bar!
It looks like a fancy cafe!
Maybe it's a bit more fancy than Buffy and Buzzy.
Maybe.
Huh?
I don't know.
What kind of food do you think they sell?
I don't think they have doughnuts there, no.
Maybe they bust?
A what
Popular cool hit music.
Even though it's not Fuwafuwaa Mocomoco.
Or it wouldn't be like them.
Fuwafuwaa Mocomoco.
Is that cool or fancy?
I tried to make it cool or fancy, Moco-chan!
I don't know.
I need more instruments.
Can you give me more instruments?
Is that an instrument?
That's just a backing vocal!
Well, it definitely has cool music.
Today's question is...
It's the annual plum season again!
I used two large jars this year.
If nothing goes wrong, I can drink them until the end of the year after next, and then use the new ones.
FUWAMOCO, do you like plums?
Why are you afraid of the sourness?
BAU BAU!
Ruffians.
We love plums!
And it looks like so much fun in the forms that you set too, you know?
Putting all the plums and making plum?
Oh syrup!
Syrup, maybe!
That would be super yummy!
We like umeboshi and anything plum flavored!
Yeah, and dried plums too!
They're good for you!
I just like them.
Umeboshi incident!
I don't remember.
Morning-chan.
Hi?
Yeah.
But we hope it went so well!
Yeah!
I'd like to try doing this one day too.
Right!
I wanna make that one.
Have fun FUWAMOCO!
Thank you so much Ruffians for all your submissions!
Not just you know, your questions, your Doggie of the Day, your Pero Sighting, your vlogs.
Thank you also for sharing you know, all your special memories, feelings with us.
What FUWAMOCO Morning means to you?
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
It means so much!
After today, it will be the 150th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
We'll still be looking for more questions!
You don't hear the name Pero Sightings?
I don't know what you think it's doing.
Nobody needs to know this question.
I just answered the question.
And don't forget to use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
BAU BAU!
Thank you for making FUWAMOCO Morning together with us, FUWAMOCO!
Let's continue for another 150 episodes!
BAU BAU!
And next, we have...
It's a dream coming up.
Listen, I'm a Ruffian, so no don't yell.
You wanna know?
I wanna know, Moco-chan, let's take a look.
Share with the Ruffians!
Yeah, we're gonna be chatting!
POPT!
Today we're going to be chatting about the traveling we did.
We took a mini vacation.
Our first mini vacation.
And we went and saw a bunch of places.
So we want to share some photos with you.
Talk about where we was and that.
The kind of experiences we had.
How trouble we got into.
Yeah!
Definitely no trouble.
So please come listen to Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And!
We also have a brand new schedule!
Do you wanna see the schedule?
I'm excited for this week!
I wanna show it to the Ruffians so we have to wait!
Schedule, yeah.
Yes!
De-den!
Our schedule!
Like I mentioned, tonight at 6pm we're gonna be chatting about a travel we did, but on Tuesday starting at 6pm PT, we're gonna be starting Metal Gear Solid 3!
It's been a little while.
Just a little bit.
A year since we last played Metal Gear Solid 2!
But we're gonna be continuing through with Metal Gear Solid 3 on the PS2!
Yeah, it's slated.
Everything's working.
We're all good to go.
Check that it's working.
It is working.
Kept us waiting, huh?
Kind of, huh?
We have a memory card.
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO And then on Wednesday we're gonna be having fun!
Good morning!
Then on Thursday I think we're gonna get a little bit busy!
At 3am PT we're gonna be doing
FUWAMOCO May Cafe is gonna be open again!
May Cafe Totsumachi!
We're gonna be, you know, opening the cafe once more.
What kind of customers will join us?
Will we get any customers?
Are we gonna go out of business?
I hope we do!
What?!
I hope we get customers!
Not that we go out of business, Moco-chan!
BAU BAU.
But we're gonna do our best and hopefully we can come up with some new menu items.
And then on Thursday, it's a little bit different.
On Thursday evening at 6pm, we're gonna be having a Rock n' Wood Party!
The first one in a long time!
In a little while.
But this time we also have a special announcement.
Special announcement.
So we hope that you look forward to that in the afterword!
Well, we're gonna have more fun.
Because it's time for Doggy Code Country 2!
And 10PLPT!
We'll do our best to get as far as we can!
We're getting pretty close to the end now, the final boss.
We just need to say it right.
Let's hope we don't die before we see you.
And on Friday starts with another FUWAMOCO Morning!
And at 5pm PT, we're gonna be starting off our mini horror game matsuri!
It's gonna be like a bunch of different horror games!
Short horror games!
We don't know if some will work.
Are some gonna be too membe?
Are some gonna be really scary?
Are we gonna complete some of them?
We don't know.
We don't know what games we're gonna play yet.
But we'll have a lot of fun together, Ruffians!
Hopefully it doesn't be too scary.
But, you know, in between, we're also gonna do, you know, have a nice little moment because we're gonna be doing some fishing!
Yeah!
Let the whole wide land come!
BAU BAU!
And fishing!
Yeah, and then on Saturday we're gonna continue at midnight!
Right after fishing.
A hoage matsuri.
Advent!
We continue on with more exciting things for iSchedule, so please look forward to it, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
And for Ruffians joining us in the Icom today, your FUWAMOCO word is... BAU BAU!
150 Mornings with you!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much Ruffians!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 150th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Jake Joestar!
BAU BAU!
I know my many names!
FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Chuudon.
Minty.
BAU BAU!
SWG.
Sherry S. BAU BAU!
Nopsa.
BAU BAU!
Vima.
Paladine.
BAU BAU!
Bye Bye Dose.
Aradaka.
BAU BAU!
Baby Notte.
Happy Toys!
BAU BAU!
Biscuit!
Blue Coins!
BAU BAU!
Tamoto-kun!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!